foreign
[Music]
I'm really excited to talk to you today
about getting data science in your
customers hands quickly and on a budget
using rstudio connect this is an
unconventional use of this product which
is really geared towards internal apps
and resources but I wanted to show you
how you can use this product for
customer facing applications as well as
internal ones but before I get into that
I want to set the scene for how we
started using our studio connect to
publish customer-facing data science
applications
it was back in the summer of 2020. we
all remember but maybe would like to
forget that time in addition to being in
the middle of a lockdown and without
child care my family and I had moved in
with my in-laws to get some extra
support moreover my wife had gone full
time on her own new business back in
January 2020 while I had joined a
startup as the first technical employee
in February 2020. needless to say it was
a stressful time
I have a feeling this is a picture many
of you with kids have or at least can
relate to if you don't have kids just
imagine everything you're doing back in
summer 2020 if I had a two-year-old and
a four-year-old to the mix as all this
was going on my company 202 group was
dealing with a problem
we had built a good streamlined data
pipeline we had sourced the necessary
data we needed to make actionable
insights for our customers and built the
methods to address and store that data
we had effective ways to analyze and
model the data and customize
visualizations for end customers we're
using open data and data science to
expose risk in critical national
security supply chains and our customers
were clamoring for more so they could
take action
but despite this tested problem this
tested process we had a problem
we had a really poor UI ux if you could
even call it that we were delivering
everything in PDFs PowerPoint and Excel
CSV files
this is a big problem for two reasons
the first is that once PowerPoints or
PDFs or spreadsheets left our inbox it
was immediately out of date the customer
could still get value out of it but they
relied on us emailing them updates which
were out of date almost immediately they
needed an on-demand up to up-to-date
data the second problem was that it
wasn't an appealing way for the customer
consuming the analysis
at first you might not think that's such
a big problem but if your customer
doesn't like the way they interact with
your product they won't use it so if you
actually want your analysis to be
anything more than a science project you
need to make sure your customer likes
the way they interact with it and for us
as a small bootstrap startup our
customer liking the product meant still
being in business by the end of the year
the customer needed to be able to
explore on their own in a user-friendly
way and get the data into formats that
they were comfortable with it needed to
be dynamic to fix the stale data problem
and the static interface problem
but we had other requirements as well we
needed to get this out the door quickly
in the next few weeks not months and we
didn't have very much money to do it
last but certainly not least we needed
something where we could continue to
focus on the data science portion of our
company the thing that was
differentiating us the value we're
actually delivering to customers was the
data science finding not the interface
itself learning web development
Technologies like CSS HTML JavaScript
PHP would not only be a distraction it
would actively detract from our time
developing the data science which was
where we were really driving value
So based on all this we developed a set
of five criteria we would use to
evaluate the proposed solutions to this
problem of getting up-to-date data
science products in our customers hands
it had to be cheap like a few thousand
dollars tops it had to be easy to use we
needed to be able to focus on the data
science and not spend a lot of time
figuring out web Technologies
it had to be easy to customize our
customers were still figuring out what
they wanted and we needed to be able to
adapt and make changes quickly and
easily the user had to log into an
interface the customer needed to be able
to access up-to-date info when they
needed it emailing staff reports had to
add and last we had to retain our IP
getting locked in with a vendor didn't
seem like a good idea and we wanted to
maintain flexibility in the future if we
started doing something new
so we settled on three options we
considered third-party Bia tools like
Tableau or power bi hiring a front-end
developer and last are Studio connect
some of my teammates were pushing for
this option I was against it for a few
reasons the startup costs are actually
pretty expensive which is a big driver
for us at this point but there are two
other perhaps more important reasons one
is that learning to use one of these
tools was really a poor use of our time
we already knew how to use our markdown
in shiny why learn how to use one of
these tools when we could be developing
data science if we were going to use
these tools and learn how to use them
from scratch we might as well learn
JavaScript ourselves these tools might
Market themselves as easy to use but in
practice I don't think it's really that
easy especially if you want to produce
something appealing
second is that we get locked into the
vendor and switching costs would be high
anything we developed would be specific
to the vendor's product and we lose
flexibility if we want to do something
else
so third-party bi tools hit two out of
three I was ready to move on
what about hiring for this need the
problem here was that it wasn't going to
be cheap to get someone good and while
it might be easier than doing it
ourselves it would be hard to Source on
good and then manage them through the
process we also want to stay focused on
our value which was in the data science
and hiring outside of that would also
have been a distraction if we were going
to hire we'd want to hire another data
scientist or engineer
so better than the third party tools but
still only three out of five
so this left us with our studio connect
I was only familiar with this product
because I had goofed around enough in
our studio IDE and clicked on this
button here the publish button
this was really helpful when I published
a Blog using our pubs so the idea of a
button in the r Studio IDE to publish
our markdown and share them securely was
really appealing
then when we got in touch with our
astute with our studio about using
connect I found out about the small
business discount this made this option
Far and Away cheaper than the other
options we considered and since we got
to keep using our markdown we didn't
have vendor lock in and we retained all
our own IP
so checks across the board
they checked all the boxes which is why
we use it going in but the reason why we
continued to use it and I'm such an
evangelist for it now is what made it so
we were able to change update and push
content quickly we could respond to
customers both in terms of access and
data within minutes and as time went on
we were iteratively able to learn more
web and front-end Technologies and
incorporate them into the end product
this included custom CSS and JavaScript
to give our products a unique look and
feel and better user experience with
only minimal front-end needs
so we've gone to the point based on
customer needs and where we are as a
company then we now do deliver a product
in a custom JavaScript PHP front-end
with a dedicated front-end team
and now we use our studio connect for
its more conventional purpose of Hosting
internal products but what's awesome is
that everything we developed was in our
markdown so those rendered HTML docs and
Graphics could be used by our by our
front-end Developers
so I want you to think about our story
and how it might work for you if you're
a small business or even individual and
you're not sure how to get your data
science into your customers hands think
of our studio connect it's cheap easy to
use Easy to update your update your
products lets your customers log into an
interface and lets you retain all your
IP without vendor lock-in
please feel free to reach out to talk
about this or anything else thank you so
much for your time and coming to hear my
talk
[Music]